ce que vous me dites souvent cette
église est saisi
pour faire bon
pendant ce temps là
à cannes
rené à 99 ans florence en a 23 depuis un
an et demi ils sont colocataires
moteur
avant si vous voulez pourquoi est ce que
vous avez envie de faire une colocation
avec florence et ça passe le temps
l on discute
pourquoi fin pour faire la morte avant
que fleurance arrive vous viviez tout
c'est
l'épousé d'origine
c'était le premier confinement vous
l'avez vécu salle oui oui oui pour
mettre à mort et c'était difficile ah je
suis du figé où il parce que quand vous
retrouver entre quatre murs
est prête pour ne pas les murs et
aient de quoi vous discutez quand vous
êtes tous les deux du goût de tous
du brutal de revenir et puis du parti du
passé aussi vous avez plein d'histoires
prenez les plans d'histoire
il ya des expressions super drôle
ccd expression de 4 pour se voir de
partout le monde entier parce qu'il
avoue voyager en fait dans coeur je veux
le mexique aussi
c'était la joie
mexicaine les avez jamais vus d'enrico
ciccone
crussy
devine toutes les pièces on les partage
mais la chambre c'est vraiment prenait
sa chambre à lui est celle ci c'est un
champ
florence et rené se sont rencontrés
grâce à l'association toit en tandem il
existe deux types de contrats entre
colocataires dans le premier le jeune
est simplement hébergé et sa présence le
soir et le week end est occasionnel le
loyer se situe alors entre 150 et 400
euros par mois dans le second le jeune
s'engage à une présence régulière et les
modalités de la colocation sont alors
défini au cas par cas
en fait ils cherchent des gens qui sont
compatibles et ils ont trouvé que nos
profils se lier bien ensemble qui se
mariait bien parce qu'on aime et tous
les deux voyages et on aimait aller au
parc que c'est pas juste la compagnie
pour les jeunes mais c'est aussi le fait
que c'est beaucoup moins cher qu après
ce après alois couvrez-vous oui monsieur
moi mon loyer je fais 35 euros par mois
lui le fait pas non plus pour les sous
c'est la compagnie quoi c'est vraiment
symbolique l'engagement c'est la
compagnie quoi d'être là mais si par
exemple si un jour où je peux pas être
là le week-end je serai sûr de faire une
activité avec rené pour compenser mais
ça vient naturellement quoi c'est pas
compter les heures et tout ça c'est
juste passer du temps ensemble bolat
s'il n'est pas bien je vais m'occuper de
lui mais lui il fait pareil pour moi par
exemple j'ai pas au début octobre
j'étais un peu malade s'est occupé de
moi ils m'avaient préparé des tisanes et
tout ça c'est normal quoi c'est ce qu'on
fait pour des colocataires ne sais pas
si je ne m'occupe pas du tout de lui il
sait il est indépendant et en accord
avec rené rose pour recevoir des amis
dans l'appartement et même son petit ami
et comme dans n'importe quelle
colocation elle cherche ses courses et
sa vie quotidienne
c'est vraiment une belle rencontre
humaine et je pense que c'est aussi le
fait que c'est aussi nos familles qui
s'entendent bien par exemple mes parents
se sont super bien entendu avec la fille
de rené et rené aussi s'entend bien avec
mes parents chaque fois que je les
appelle ils demandent de leur parler un
peu c'est sympa c'est comme un grand
père d'adoption exactement c'est ça
c'est ça c'est exactement ça qui font
qu'on s'amuse